did you know you can create an agent to
have conversations with your end users
by just providing a website link or
documents with vertex AI conversation
you can Parts your content and create a
virtual agent powered by large language
models this agent can have conversations
about the content with your end users
and allows you to create conversational
experiences such as an FAQ agent that
answers frequently asked questions a
website agent that answers questions
based on your website's content an
employee facing agent to help and
support questions using internal help
desk or HR support documents and so much
more vertex AI conversation provides a
straightforward orchestration interface
that lets developers build apps in hours
and days with little or no coding and no
prior machine learning experience want
to create your own agent all you'll need
to get started is a domain name and or
any number of documents that you'd like
to upload and vertex AI conversation
will index them and create a virtual
agent for your end users to
conversationally get the answers they
need check out our documentation to see
what languages are currently supported
and learn how to create an agent
yourself